I won't show it if you don't want me to
put it up on the screen that we can hide
your we can hide your handle but there
are a lot of shall I say there were a
number of risque photos on your
Instagram yeah and so it's interesting
to me like I I was kind of shocked
actually to to hear that you were in a
relationship and you had a boyfriend and
it's you know he's nowhere to be found
on on your Instagram and not only that
there are pictures that are I would
normally associate with a single girl
who's sort of advertising herself to
other men so I'm kind of curious as to
your thoughts on that is that something
that um like most of those photos that
were taken that was before I had my
boyfriend um so we've already had like
that discussion where it's like you
know it's off got me curious right but
like the point is right you had those
you had those pictures taken when you
were single right they posted when you
were single yeah and you had let's call
it you had your for sale sign up you had
your for sale sign in the windshield hey
like I'm a super I'm a Lamborghini or
whatever it is I'm for sale here's how
here's my number then I know a call if
you're interested and somebody comes
along and says okay great I I'm private
right now this is now okay I won't put
it up on the screen if she doesn't I'll
unprivate it um but it is on private is
it's now as if the picture it's it's
like if the car is sold I'll share it
how about that let me share it I'll
share it really quick let me see hold on
well there's a dude here on the top
right I'm guessing this is the boyfriend
it is so much love for you there you go
see which one is that and then two
pictures over we got a whole lot of uh
boute oh I don't see the boyfriend photo
oh the which one is that top right my my
boyfriend took
the one phot oh there is okay that's
that's that's new that must have like
just been
uploaded um no that was up for a bit
okay do you it wasn't there earlier
that's what I'm saying let me let me
show it really let me just share it
really quick do you get any push back
from him over the uh risque photography
no he actually took he actually took the
the photo that's in the middle and he
saw me take the other ones all those
other photos the last bottom ones were
prior to my relation ship with him that
was when I was extremely single
extremely Super Single extreme we get
Super Single meaning like I was on my
own path to find myself to just kind of
focus on me my daughter my life just
kind of like getting my confidence back
after being out of like an unhealthy
relationship that I was just doing
myself and doing the things that I you
know you know what is the the difference
between single and Super Single Super
Single meaning like I'm super single
like I'm finding myself after being in
such a hard relationship that has like
you know made me made me what do you
think guys here when you say I'm finding
myself when I'm finding myself that I'm
kind of just well chat right now tell us
tell us what you hear when a woman says
I'm finding myself but em please explain
it what I mean or what a guy might
portray that as well like like I want
men to sort of like step in and stay
what they interpret that as but I'm
wondering what you mean when you say by
finding when I say that I'm finding
myself it means like you know I just
went through a really difficult time in
my life and right now I need to focus on
me and my daughter so it's like my
family is like me finding myself because
I need to bring myself back to that
character I was before I became broken
so I need to repair any damage that had
been done so I can still be me and be
the person and mother that my daughter
needs me to be so so in the chat they're
um giving us
this oh yeah they're giving us some
promiscuity statements what about when a
guy says up because I've gotten that
what's that when a guy says he's working
on himself it's not usually usually when
a guy says he's working on himself he's
going to the gym or going to dojo and
learning how to fight or
Lear he's telling you that he doesn't
want to be in a relationship with you
because he's working on himself yeah he
do relationship material yeah yeah he
doesn't see you as a girlfriend yeah
yeah I think it just kind of goes book
like it like it's like it's could be a
Friends with Benefits could be like a
you know like a low value like
interaction to him one night or
something like that but he doesn't see
you as somebody that he wants to invite
into his life yeah I don't I don't know
if I got an answer to my question before
about the first sales I'm Cur like if he
he asked you if he asked you to take
those photos down would you yes 100%
he but he you said he took them for you
yeah so like like I had mentioned the
photo that was me with the palm trees in
the background with my white um like
beach cover um he had taken that when we
just went on our trip together uh the
other one was taken again like his
bathing suit is in the background on the
chair there so those are like those few
things but everything else prior to that
like was me and my best friend in
Florida or me with my friends on a yacht
in Toronto or I guess my question is
like who are those pictures for who owns
the yacht in
Toronto a friend a friend and I'm
assuming the friend is not a woman
because women don't usually own Yachts
so no it was one of my friends that I
had met through um doing like when my
friends were doing promo in during like
club events and stuff and I was actually
on the beach and I asked these guys like
hey like we can you rent seos because I
had my license on me I wanted to go um
so when I had went to go rent the SEO
there the guy was no longer there and
they're like hey you don't have to rent
seedos just come with us and you can
come on our boat so we were like oh okay
so we got on the seedos and they drove
us over to the yacht and then we ended
up on a yacht for like the whole entire
day and became friends with like at
least like 10 to 15 different people mhm
um it was fun like I was single so like
I felt no way about going and you know
having memories and making these
memories with people um they are really
good successful people um you know the
the guy who does own the yacht he has
his own Building Company he builds many
projects all around Toronto and GTA the
other few guys on there does like car
wraps stuff like that you know they are
really nice guys um and
they were nice enough to invite us on to
their yacht and we all hung out and it
wasn't just like me and my friend there
was other girls and we went up and there
was like about 15 20 different Yachts
that were tied together and it was just
like that to get together in Toronto
that people have you were with your
boyfriend at the time no I was single
single then Super
Single no not super sing I was looking
at that time but I also like just was
not looking okay yeah we're yeah we're
learning tonight and you know the other
shows you know differ between single
Super
Single extremely single like there's
like there's variations of single out
there that you know we must comprehend
as men when we understand these things
um you were asking about something MF
before I um interrupted asking about the
yacht I just wanted
to oh no I think what I was where I was
going with it's like I'm always curious
like who are these pictures for right
like oh got the boyfriend you know they
were taken when you were single you know
why why continue to have those pictures
of I have no issue taking them down like
I said I've talked to my boyfriend about
it he does not care whatsoever about
these photos being on there um if I were
to get married obviously those photos
would be taken down um I know that you
guys are thinking okay well what's the
difference between you getting married
and you being in a relationship right
now and I understand that however I am
Young I am only 24 years old and my mom
kind of said like you know you're young
you're not going to have this body
forever it doesn't mean I have to show
the whole world it but you know I am
proud of the growth that I've done in
the gym for myself and for my body and
it's very similar to guys as well like
guys don't public platform photos
Instagram is a public platform I mean
there's In fairness she did have it as a
as a private setting until she opened it
up public but yeah I think the point
that M's getting at is if you're in a
relationship and you're putting
photographs like risque photographs of
of yourself out there you're essentially
saying hey guys look at me I'm over here
check it out right and that invites uh
comments and DMS and attention from guys
that aren't the guy that you committed
to so hence why it's private because
when I got in a relationship it became
private and the only time it went on
private was when we went to Cuba so I
could tag the resort in it because we
were doing like this contest thing okay
cool yeah just it's just something to be
mindful of I mean if you want like if
you care about the relationship and he's
a guy that you've committed to like you
wanted to claim him and be like hey
where do we stand where is this going
then I think it's incumbent on women to
take the steps necessary to protect that
relationship so that you're not
marketing yourself out there to other
people right I agree um some some women
don't like that because they like the
attention but at the end of the day you
know the guy can also decide at that
time well I can't take a woman seriously
that does that I will also say like me
being self-aware of also my photos being
up there it's also kind of
like there's going to be days that you
don't feel confident about yourself and
your partner probably sees like all
these other girls and they're half naked
photos on social media right and it's
like I don't post them since like we've
been together obviously other than the
ones that you know he has seen and is a
well aware that I have put up there um
but it's almost similar to like it's
like you just don't want to be not left
out because I wouldn't consider it that
but I would consider it
like I don't feel insecure but there's
times where I could feel insecure about
myself and it's like what if my
boyfriend's liking other girls bikini
photos and like you know I don't post
those photos but he's going to go like
other girls photos you know like it's
kind of like one of those things where
like I can you know be self-aware about
it and be like he like I like having my
own like bikini photo or something yeah
I can promise you that he's going to
look I mean if there's any attractive
woman that like passes his line of sight
in his day-to-day activity or if he's on
a phone and on an app or something and
there's a recommended something what
he's gonna look I mean his friends send
him like half naked bikini photos all
the time like literally every time he
opens up his phone his friend is sending
him like some naked girl on Instagram
I'm like okay because women are Beauty
objects though right my friends don't
send me half naked guy photos of like
that's because guys are success objects
they're not Beauty objects that's then
why do the guys out in the gym think of
them as Beauty objects I don't think
guys that work out in the gym think of
themselves as Beauty object you should
see some of the guys that I mean they'll
they'll they'll work out so that they
aesthetically look pleasing naked but
why do they have to share it on social
media Edge just like girls right but
they're just they're shorts I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out